what are your thoughts on someone like
Hilaria Baldwin like fully adopting a
Spanish accent you hear about that no I
don't even know who this is Gloria
Baldwin is Alec Baldwin's um wife and he
grew up in the United States but she
used to spend some summers in Spain and
then now she speaks uh like these like
Spanish but American accent oh and
people are calling her out on it and
being like hey like you're kind of like
I don't know that yeah I don't know
either I don't know anything about
anything about it if I knew about it I'd
have a comment
but I I could come on on this right yeah
um I know that you know um you can't
pick up an accent if you were raised you
know I mean as a kid so you can yeah you
can't there's what it gets to a point in
your age development that if you if I
was raised in America for 10 years and I
went to Australia I would pretty much
still have an American accent oh yeah
yeah that is true don't you think that's
probably what happened to me I lived in
Australia for 10 years yeah because I
see I hear a lot of Australian when you
talk you do oh I do like what what's
Australia what the [__] was that by the
way
who can't do it what's Australian what
do I say that's Australian
it just I I don't know a specific word
they're just there is a um Australian
undertone to it really yeah to when
you're talking wow there is a little
[__] [__] too in there oh that's oh
that's so that's the self-hating company
self-hating Asian no what what you know
you don't you have a bit about that what
about what how black people have the
n-word and then you say the g word how
is that related to what you just said
what I'm saying is is that I can use the
word [__] oh yeah but the you but you oh
on another Asian you can use another
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah but you
when you say it there's no love behind
it what do you mean there's no love yeah
you're saying it because you and I saw
each other on the street right I go
what's up Duke you would never do that
why because my [__] because was that my
[__] yeah when you say that there's so
much hatred behind it okay that's why
when you say me you don't say it because
you don't hate me okay I want to do it
so that it feels authentic and it feels
there's no way to do this yeah I'm gonna
try I'm gonna try and we're walking down
the street I see you I'm walking what's
up
I don't think I hey what's up [__] oh
yeah I don't think I don't think I don't
think you can use Google in any way I'll
go what's up dude that's an owl set up
dude yeah right but the thing is what's
coming up what's coming out of you is
this agent self-hatred and we can all
hear it that's why it's not working I
don't have no stop stop
all right you have self-hatred as well
holy [__] yeah yeah why do you hate your
people this is not Jedi Minecraft
okay I love my people and I want to say
that I was raised with a lot of Wyatts
and when I moved to LA
um 20 plus years ago I was amongst you
know that's you know I've been trying to
reach out I've been trying to become
more of who I am connected you know okay
when you're raised in the suburbs you
try to conform and you know you there's
also these little micro aggressions that
happens and then you absorb all that
stuff right and now as taking a lot of
people yeah I'm trying to I love you man
thank you man I appreciate it yeah I
love you so much thank you do you think
that there is an upside to having been
like Asian growing up somewhere else
like I think there is first I think
there's upside he's more evolved
like from certainly no please let him
continue
hold that thought I could feel like but
I do want to think like when I
froze 15 I was like you people like you
had the advantage because I was like oh
he grew up here he doesn't have like you
know he doesn't need to live in this
limbo of like where the [__] do I belong
I was a fob but then now I think I have
the advantage you do because like I have
a true sense of like I don't know like
my Asian identity doesn't feel
challenged ever because it's like I grew
up in the Philippines I speak the
language like I feel very connected to
it like I can understand how yours is a
little bit more like fracture that
identity does that make sense I do feel
that
yeah I I um I don't know who I am
whoa this is this is a this is man I'm
not being real I don't know who I am and
I want to know more about who I am or
where I come from and the culture and
all that stuff but I don't know how and
I don't think it'll ever happen well
let's do a show my work here is done
body [__] did it man but I did it but
but that being said that being said I am
very proud of myself like when you go to
Korea do you feel I love who I am do you
feel like less than in Korea I feel like
a nobody
because it's like they don't have like
in the Philippines if you're jokoy right
he's going to be because they speak
English they love you know American
culture I mean the music films and
whatnot right but in Korea it's like
they have their own thing going on so
when I'm over whenever I'm there nobody
knows who I am not a single person right
and I just feel like a complete alien
but in a good way
what do you mean like you know good way
or bad way when you go with it you feel
like oh I'm Anonymous now I can just no
you know it it is interesting right uh
in a bad way okay in a bad way yeah oh
wow yeah yeah wow okay well because you
know
because you when you're you know a an
American korean-american comedian and
some of the things that I've done in
America like last 30 years when they
don't respect it or even know about it
it hurts it doesn't okay a little bit no
you don't care I like in Singapore I say
this without bravado I say I'm not I'm
not trying to make it sound like I'm so
tough or whatever but
um I like I'm not that famous in America
I got nothing on you profile War but
like uh I don't think in Malaysia or
Singapore they really know about me and
I'm like that's your care okay I'm
totally okay with that I don't I don't
want to say I don't care as though I I
don't care what these people think it's
more like oh I first of all what we do
is counter cultural anyway if you do
stand-up comedy it's already come to
cultural like you shouldn't be looking
for everyone to give you a round of
applause already okay so that's that's
one and then two it's like I left there
to come here so why would I be angry at
them for not knowing me like what I do
isn't wasn't for them I wasn't trying to
okay okay so like what you know you're
huge in the Philippines though I don't
know about that I don't know your
massive there you're massive there what
okay there's always news in me because I
don't have any I don't tour there I
don't you know so yeah I'm don't get me
wrong I'm happy when people like what
I'm doing but it's like I how why would
I be angry at them for not knowing me
it's like they have their own thing
going on Philippines has their own
entertainment industry yeah going on
correct you're right
there's some shame there you're right no
there's no [__] I wanna you're right I
want to be better
what yeah you're right it's culture
you're so good man you're very good it's
very counter-cultural what we're doing
um
everyone's gonna love what you do right
and um I'm okay with who I am and what
I'm doing is he praying right now no I'm
not praying oh my mental yeah well learn
some actual I've learned so much about
myself today uh and I wanna I wanna grow
okay well that's all right I guess my
work so your work is not done
because we have an unhelpful advice yeah
we got a question so when the no we have
one last [__]
[Laughter]
yeah we have a family it's almost done
let's end this [__]
we have a fan five minutes five minutes
five
minutes so we have a fan question a
couple